Welcome back.
Or maybe you didn't even watch
the last video, but anyway, we
are on problem number 15.
The Acme Plumbing Company will
send a team of three plumbers
to work on a certain job.
The company has four
experienced
plumbers and four trainees.
If a team consists of one
experienced plumber and two
trainees, how many such
teams are possible?
So we're going to send three
plumbers, right?
Three plumbers.
So it's one, two, three.
And one of them has to be
experienced, right?
And then these are
inexperienced, these are trainees.
So this is the team, one
experienced and two trainees.
And now we're going to have
to pick from a set.
Let's say my four experienced
plumbers are
plumbers A, B, C, D.
These are experienced.
And let's say my trainees
are E, F, G, H.
So these four are trainees.
So how many different
experienced plumbers can I
have heading up the team?
Well, there's four
possibilities, right?
So there's four different people
I can stick in here.
Four choices, or four
possibilities.
Now, independent of who I put
into the experienced slot, how
many trainees-- let's say this
is trainee slot one and
trainee slot two, not that
there's a difference-- so now
if I'm picking who can go into
trainee slot one, how many
choices do I have?
Well, I have four choices
because none of them have been
staffed yet.
So I can put four people here.
Not four people, I'm putting one
person, but I can pick one
of four, so there's four
possibilities here.
Once I've already filled trainee
slot one, one of these
people are going to disappear.
Then the set is going to
be one less, right?
There's only going to be three
trainees left once
I've filled slot one.
So how many trainees can
I put in slot two?
Well, there's only three
possibilities I could put
because I already stuck
one in slot one.
So there's four possible
experienced people, four
possible choices for trainee
in slot one.
And then since one trainee will
already have been staffed
in slot one, there's only three
choices for slot two.
So it's 4 times 4 times 3.
So what is that?
4 times 12, which is
48 possibilities.
Next problem.
And the trick here is just
realizing that once you staff
one of the trainees, you only
have 3 left that you can put
in the other one, in the
second trainee slot.
Next problem.
Problem 16.
All right, we've got some
circles going on here.
Let me draw a circle.
So they have one circle
like that.
And they have a bigger circle
that looks something like--
oh, I don't know if I--
no, let me undo that.
Edit, undo.
OK, let me see if I can
make it more even.
That's pretty good.
OK, let me fill it in with
a pleasant color.
All right.
The figure above consists
of two circles that
have the same center.
If the shaded area is 64 pi
square inches and the smaller
circle has a radius of 6 inches,
so that distance right
there is 6, what is the
radius in inches
of the larger circle?
So, we want to figure out radius
of the larger circle.
Radius of the larger circle I'll
do in this green color.
Let's call that x.
So what's going to be the area
of the shaded circle?
How would we figure it out if
we knew the radius of the
larger circle?
What would be the area
of the large circle?
Area of the large circle minus
the area of the small circle
is going to equal
64 pi, right?
Because if the whole thing was
filled in in mauve or whatever
color this is, then it would
just be the area of the large
circle, but we're subtracting
out the area of the small
circle to get the
mauve region.
So what's the formula for the
area of the large circle?
It's pi times its
radius squared.
So we already set that radius to
be equal to x, so it's pi x
squared-- and that's what we're
trying to figure out in
this problem-- minus the area
of the small circle.
What's the area of
the small circle?
Well, its radius is 6 so
it's pi r squared, so
it's pi times 6 squared.
And that is going to
be equal to 64 pi.
And just to simplify things, we
can just divide both sides
by pi just to get them
out of the way.
But you don't have to do that,
that just simplifies things
for my simple mind.
So you get x squared minus
36 is equal to 64.
Add 36 to both sides, you get
x squared is equal to 100.
So x could be equal-- if you
just solved it, it would be
plus or minus 10, and of course,
a radius can't be
negative, so it's plus 10.
So x is 10, or the radius of
the larger circle is 10.
Next problem.
Problem 17.
If p, r, and s are three
different prime numbers
greater than two-- let me just
write them down, p r, and s--
three different prime numbers
greater than two and n is
equal to p times r times s, how
many factors including one
and n does n have?
How many factors?
This is a good problem.
This is essentially the prime
factorization of n, right?
And we want to know how many
positive factors including 1
and n, right?
So what are all of
the factors here?
So if we just made a factor
tree-- let's make a
combination of all the numbers
that when I multiply the pair
can equal n.
So one times n is equal to n.
Another number that would equal
n is pr times s would
also equal n, right?
Because obviously p times r
times s is n, so p times r
times s is n, but I'm saying p
times r is a number, right?
Hopefully that makes
some sense.
Similarly, we could say that
p times rs is equal to n.
Same logic.
I'm saying r times s
is a number, right?
Some number.
And then finally we could say
that sp times r, with sp as a
number, is also equal
to n, right?
So all of these numbers that I
said-- 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7,
8-- all of these numbers
are factors of n.
So that's how many factors there
are, there are eight
factors including 1 and n.
If this seemed a little bit
abstract to you, try it out
with some numbers.
Actually, that's the best way
you could do it if this was
too abstract.
You could say, what if p is
3, r is 5, and s is 7.
Then what is n?
Well, n is going to
be 15 times 7.
So n is 15 times 7,
what is that?
70 plus 35, n is 105.
So if n is 105, this
is 1 times 105.
pr, this is 15 times 7.
This would be 3 times 35.
Is that right?
Oh no, sorry, 85.
No, sorry.
If 5 times 7 is 35 times 3,
oh right, it's 105, right?
So we would write 3 times 35,
and sp is 21 times 5.
So those would be the
actual numbers.
So hopefully that makes a little
bit more sense to you.
But this is the way you could
do it in a general way.
It looks like I'm running out
of time, so I will do number
18 in the next video.
But this is a little bit of
a non-intuitive problem.
Just remember, this is the prime
factorization, and then
you can construct its--
what I call the normal
factorization-- you can
construct that by just taking
combinations of the
prime numbers.
And hopefully the actual numbers
make a little bit more
sense to you.
See you in the next video.